hey youtubers is Charlie sons Gary Maher
episode 2 video there's also been
allotted
DC movie news Sol cover that you have to
get the aerostat in
we had a good look at when the brain new
characters komodo for this season
be found it with the has been in we
gonna be teaser for another giant art
its gonna go across the first happen in
season your first bosnia pursued if you
haven't seen it yet but
starting with top five moments you get
number five team a rogue reads
so this is definitely probably one of
the most cry where the episodes in a row
ever
obviously everyone's greeting for Sarah
she's definitely dead be buried her
put her in the ground a lot of you guys
have been asking me about the Lazarus
Pit
no I don't either going to use that
obviously they want to advance
morals Black Canary story arc in they
can't do that once they're still alive
I think the speed with which they killed
Sarah
tells you about how fast they wanna
dance that moral story line obviously
at the end of the episode she was
staring at the jacket is a love story
lines being teased
but I think it's going to be a while
before your gets there it could happen
as soon as the midseason finale
it might take to the end of the season
aside from the horror of having to stare
at their is dead body
Pawlenty miro is trying to grieve in
their own way oliver obviously
not doing so well I did all the malarkey
that he speaking about being a leader is
what gives Felicity the bomb
to go work for Ray Palmer for those
wondering about the repo mixed up
there's nothing
sexual going on there he just wants her
to come work for him
just because she's really smart number
for publicity goes to work for a polymer
felicity is going to be the bridge
between team arrow
Henry Palmer obviously Ray Palmer at
some point is going to have to cross
paths
with the Aero even the candidate in the
episode did anyone else catch the blue
green industries logo to
that was pretty surreal in the
background in the really interesting
thing about me Palmer that's only been
teasing his character description
is that he's hiding you know some sort
of lost that he suffered but he hasn't
told anyone about
i think is Mike died under unfortunate
circumstances and
just like Malcolm Merlyn turned it legal
assassins re Palmer is gonna
turned to fighting crime to try and turn
it into something positive
re Palmer just happens to be a texting
is billionaire so
hopefully at some point we'll get to see
in kick some butt
the title the midseason finale there's
two parts to it is chairpersons flash
that's the flash absurd
the Aeros I did that is called The Brave
and the bold so I'm assuming re Palmer
is gonna get tied up
in some certainty mara plot at that
point whether or not he learns all over
secret identity before that remains to
be seen
number three Laurel wants the fight back
so this is all very clearly part of her
arc to be coming Black Canary
that's why they're headed I her death is
the call to action
more on the did enduring that burial
seen obviously decal said
they would name the baby Sarah to honor
her memory but
world will probably take on the mantle
Black Canary to honor her memory as well
I thought that was a big easter egg no
one will remember her name so i'm going
to honor her by
taking on the mantle in the UK she get
really excited about though is Laurel in
training
I V series of the A train into the
episode the same kind of thing is going
to happen with moral
don't know exactly how it's gonna go
down but we do know that Wildcat
is gonna be part team a row at some
point and this is going to be on the
show
having scenes with Laurel so the prior
gonna be doing some training
we only saw him briefly in that first
episode
fighting in the boxing ring you is you
know team Wildcat so we'll see how he in
Laurel end up crossing paths
eventually in the comics wildcard is
very famous for having trained several
big Justice League a-listers had a fight
at least the human ones in no I do not
think he's going to be wearing their
classic wild cat costume
I am really happy to see Katie Cassidy
get this big story arc
I wasn't a huge fan of her in season two
I think that was kinda the point though
like she had hit rock bottom before she
could worker way back up to the top
but if you look at Katie Cassidy she
actually has like some serious guns
honor
right now like it's crazy how much he's
been working out I think in terms that
filming their past episode 10 or they're
filming up to 10 right about now
so she's is going to get bigger and
bigger until we get to the finale
over doesn't really look like he has the
mental capacity to handle training
someone right now
so i think thats why Laurel is gonna
turned to Wildcat for training
we also can't forget about her pulling
the trigger on a gun she actually tried
to shoot komodo she tried to kill 'em
all the big moment I would say that was
one of the bigger WTS
was her pulling the trigger she would've
been a murder had Olver not had the
foresight to take the boat out again
number two me komodo he's been played by
Matt Ward
but in the comics he's an enemy a volver
Queens obviously the show's doing
something a little bit different with
them
he seems a little bit more ambiguous
accuse a hired assassin
eased its not like straight up trying to
kill team a row somebody hired him to
kill people
did are behind the Star City Development
at Sri palmer's big planned to
revitalize the city
aside from a commercial in there only
couple other people on the show that we
know about
a couple bad characters damn I want to
derail that big development
one is obviously vertigo because he's
pushing drugs all over the city
the other is racial Gould we don't
really know what the characters gonna be
doing on the show yet so it's a little
early to start throwing him into the mix
como do for now obviously is not dead
but he will show up again this season
but just to be clear I do not think that
he's working from a commercial and
in my number one moment T Miro Barry
Sears body
this is like the moment eulogy obviously
over made a big deal about not grieving
earlier in the episode
he is grieving now like that's
especially with the last moment the
episode where about
when he was Gary to contact via and even
said it himself
I don't wanna die down here be really
interested to see how he tries to dig
himself
added that emotional whole I'm easy's
turning to be a first
because in her story arc this season
that's obviously going to be covering
some big problems for him
that's actually the 10 love the next
episode corto mattie's
he and where gonna be going down there
to try and binder
just like Tommy went to Hong Kong to
find oliver
it was meant to be a serious seen but it
was really fun think on O'Donnell
he actually appeared at comic-con with
Stephen Amell like Stephen Amell was
doing a regular old
comic-con panel just by himself con
O'Donnell happened to be there
and just sat on the panel with them it
was awesome just couple Bros just like
all times
important thing to remember about sears
debt is that it's not
over like obviously they're going to be
consequences you all over is going to
visit consequences on
whoever did this to her he's gonna find
out with
it is they're also had other people in
her life they're gonna want some justice
namely miss al Gold over specifically
invoked the legal assassins during the
episode he said there'd been trained by
some of the best teams in the world
IVC talking about the league I don't
know who will be next week's episode but
eventually miss out cool will be back on
the show
in obviously racial gore will come to
through the question now is who killed
Sarah and why
I think it was probably somebody inside
the league assassins
but I don't think it was me chuckle and
sell and I don't think it was missile
cool
it doesn't leave a whole lot other
people it possible but there's a bill in
did they haven't announced yet in right
now I think they will be written up to
like episode 12 or 13
so they're still like 10 episodes after
that so they're just a whole lotta
characters they haven't decided on yet
is also Amanda Waller to remember she
ordered all heard
to kill his best friend Tommy Merlin
it's possible that she's also behind
sarah is dat
like she ordered the hit like a suicide
squad member to kill her
but let me know what was your favorite
moment in the episode and who do you
think killed sarin
overall again the absurd a solid b-plus
just for doing such a great job
morning a day character they really do
go out on a limb when they do episodes
like this
their big downers I mean it's very
depressing episodes very depressing
subject they're so good at doing action
sometimes you forget that they're really
good
with drama to that's why I'm so excited
about the Israel and I think she's gonna
be drama to the show in a way that we
haven't seen before
is is going to make things much more
personal between all over in malcolm
tommy was like all birds brother but the
a very literally
is his sister so it's a family affair
between the three of them now
that level of intimacy is part of the
reason by Slade was such an effective on
last year
because he in all over had such a close
relationship either way next week is
going to be very Merlin heavy storyline
so
look forward to seeing a tenor John
Barrowman in a terrible hauling kicking
butt
top was that directed the episode airs
next week be sure to subscribe to it
also big news about the DC movie
universe so here's the schedule that
Warner Brothers has announced
really the big talk is that the movies
are gonna completely be separate from
the TV show
but they announce that at comic-con if
you like people just forgot that
to hear the movies bad members in
Superman Donna justice
2016 in the Suicide Squad movie directed
by David here
also in 2016 then there's the Wonder
Woman stand-alone movie
that's going to be in 2017 been Justice
League part 1
directed by Zack Snyder obviously gonna
be like spring summer 2017
then there's a flash stand-alone movie
starring as Remillard in 2018
back off a little bit a controversy this
morning just because you know
the Grant Gustin flash showed just
started and everyone loves him so
there's a little bit a drama because as
a miller is also playing the Barry Alan
flash
in people feel like it's been a missed
opportunity begun a den like an
african-american
Bali West in not stepped on the toes the
TV show so then we have at home and
start this memo and
that's also in 2018 leader in 2018 I
feel like that's the worst kept secret
ever
again even with the polls probably new
digits memo is going to be our command
in this this is a movie in 2019
obviously
now we know that the rock is going to be
playing Black Adam then later in 2019
there's just a sleeper to I don't know
how you guys feel about them splitting
movies into two parts
%uh explain why that's happening in a
second but then after that
is cyborg that Sri Fisher in 2020 in
Green Lantern
later in 2020 I love this got announced
during comic-con
they just didn't confirm the dates just
into the two-part Justice League WTF
step
the reason they're probably splitting
into two parts is because the ones been
those first two hours putting the team
together
in the second to defeating whatever the
big donors there is a little bit in news
on this is that Bobby to
they're considering Tom Hardy for what
are the roles an alarm US about Manu
Bennett being in it you know like the TV
show version at the Suicide Squad
obviously the film people don't care
about any the TV show people
but there's no way Stephen Amell is
going to get a cameo Justice League
in obviously Grant Gustin totally not
gonna be in a flash movie it is but a
bummer that the not doing all that
crossover stuff but
honestly I don't think it's gonna be
terrible elusive where little bit
explaining
now click here for my flash episode 2
video in
thank you for my episode 1 video thank
you so much for watching
so little high by in his have a good
pride for Katie lots
you will be missed